I'm Donna Strickland I'm a professor at
the University of Waterloo
I study lasers and in particular I like
really high intensity lasers so a laser
is a way to get light to actually just
be a single color going in a single
direction all of the waves peaking at
the same time so that the intensity can
get very high today I've been challenged
to explain lasers and high intensity
lasers at five different levels from a
child to a teenager to a college student
to a graduate student and finally to a
colleague of mine so I was told that
maybe science is one of your favorite
subjects at school is that right yes
yeah have you actually studied light yet
yes okay what have you learned so far
about light so we learn how to like
actually light up oh really
Oh excellent well I'm somebody you'd
like studies lasers so what do you think
about lasers you know you haven't gotten
to play with lasers so I brought one
that's you know my friend's cat toy do
you ever use a laser as a cat toy and
one of the fun things people do with
lasers the cat will try to grab that dot
I'm sure what you have at home is a
flashlight
I brought a cute little one so the
question is do you see any difference
between what a flashlight does and what
a laser does that's true the lace is
just a dot and so the other thing to
notice though is that this seems like
when I shine it in your eyes I am sorry
if I do but it seems awfully bright
doesn't it and yet when you know you
shine this down and you put the laser
which one do you see easier laser so
which one do you think's more powerful
and yet it's not isn't that amazing yeah
one of the things that lasers are great
for is that it because of its a directed
beam we can actually put that light
where we want the light to go and
sometimes we maybe just want to see
something around a corner and you can't
see it but with a laser you can actually
and this is a smoky one so you can
actually watch it go you see it actually
bending the corner oh and that's because
the light will go through this glass but
when it hits that corner
it has to bend and we actually sound
laser beams down glass fibers the size
of your hair yeah so this obviously is
much bigger than our hair right so this
is just a demonstration if you have a
laser like this it actually bends and
comes out I'm going to point it to you
and you'll see it coming out the other
end it hits these walls it has to go
around and come out the other side you
won't play so that's the first time
you've seen a laser have you gotten to
play with laser somewhere else I don't
so you don't need a cat so I know have
you ever gone to a grocery store and
just scanned your objects over have you
ever seen that maybe this is a little
bit of a red light when you do that
that's a laser we cut steel with them
now we actually do surgery with lasers
you know when some people have either
scars or birthmarks that they don't want
to see we can actually remove those with
lasers now we've never seen a laser
light show when they light up the sky
with lasers it's almost like fireworks
oh you got to say a shooting star well
that's that's cool that's nature giving
you the show there so what do you think
about lasers I think they're fun and the
next time you go to a grocery store take
a peek at the red okay
today we're here to talk about lasers so
what do you think about lasers um I
think they're pretty cool they show put
in a lot of my favorite books and movies
like Star Wars so just a bunch of
different sci-fi movies and books do you
know anything about lasers what makes
the laser special kind of light all I
really know is from like sci-fi books
and movies and like the factory cutting
lasers that they used to like cut steel
and stuff did it even know maybe how to
make a laser that it would be strong
enough to cut steel no okay so one of
the things about lasers is if you've
ever seen a laser beam you know it's
very directed like what are they made
out of what does a laser made out of
well really it's sort of the same thing
as a light bulb right because people to
beam so yeah it's a light bulb and
there's a couple of mirrors now the
light bulb has to be a little bit
special it has to be a type of material
that can store the energy in an excited
state right it has to stay up there
really energetic and sit there for a
while so that when the light comes along
it takes that energy and become stronger
light and then the mirror sends it back
and it does it again and again and again
and between these two mirrors it makes
the light come out in a nice beam in a
laser it comes out as a single color
they all come out with their waves at
the same time every wave peaks at the
same time which then makes it a giant
wave and it's this giant wave that has a
tremendous amount of power so it can do
something like cutting steel but when
you cut steel or if you're cutting this
floor it's great it actually will absorb
the light that's why the light you don't
see it because the light isn't bouncing
back or through it so I like to use
demos to explain how my laser works so
I've brought basically a hammer and a
nail I'm sure you've probably hammered a
nail before into a piece of wood but the
question is if you asked yourself why it
is that we hit the big end and it's the
tiny end that we put on the piece of
wood we would never pick up a hammer and
hit the sharp hit the sharp end and hope
this would go into the piece of wood
because in
to be center so can more easily just go
in that's right it's all the same force
that we apply up here goes all the way
through but then it can only basically
come out when it contacts the wood in
that one tiny spot and so sometimes it's
the force that you push something with
but sometimes it is that force per unit
area but sometimes it's not even the
force per unit area because you know
push down as hard as you can on that
that and see if we can get it pushed in
it doesn't really work does it so the
laser needs ultimately thinks it needs
well if titty centered it needs time to
like actually penetrate and then it
needs well it depends so if you're
cutting steel you need to have the nail
you need to have it concentrated all of
the light not going in all directions
but you need it into a smaller point as
possible and for that we use a lens for
a lens the lights coming down as a
column you put in a lens it all focuses
it down in the same way as the nail and
then it starts cutting that steel okay
so that's sort of force per unit area so
it's kind of like a magnifying glass
like get my good twice at lay it down to
a point exactly
you know sometimes you want to have all
of your energy not just in a small area
but in this small volume and so one of
the other dimension is time or light but
with light time and lengths are the same
thing
because light always travels at the
speed of light exactly but if you send
one second long light pulse out into the
skies there the beginning of the pulse
is actually two thirds of the way to the
moon it's three hundred thousand
kilometers long so now if you talk about
light being concentrated that doesn't
seem very concentrated the type of
lasers I play with in my lab will be no
thicker than this piece of paper so we
take that energy that might be in three
hundred thousand kilometers and we
squeeze it all the way down into just
this piece of paper and actually the
beams are more the size of this piece of
paper okay and so in my lab they would
be flying pieces of paper like this
would be flying through the sky but we
can't see them because they don't come
in our eyes they fly by us and they're
infrared
we like little concentrated beams of
light exactly where and so now if we
have light like that that we want a
machine with I bring this funnel and so
if we had a lens here the light was
coming down so funnel sent into a spot
so here would be my light coming from my
laser no just be coming down down down
down down hit a lens and we have to
focus down but now all the light started
out with this big of a spread so
concentrated this much eventually it
would be here more concentrated but by
the end right at the focal spot that's
when I get all of my light all of the
energy has been squeezed down into
fitting inside this piece of paper and
that's why I say that I built a laser
hammer because when this hits a piece of
glass it just smacks those electrons
right off the atoms and there's nothing
else for them to do they have to fly
away so can you tell me what you learned
and maybe about the focusing of the
light well what I learned is lasers they
aren't like particles they're more like
a super concentrated beam light that can
be any color they get really
concentrated and that's what makes them
like play serious and that's why they
cut things and break things because it
just moves the electrons out of the way
so do you think that lasers are fun
enough to talk with your friends about
her of course I'm gonna have to share
something about my experience learning
about lasers was an expert like you
so you're a college student yes and
what's your major I am an engineering
physics major with a minor in math I'm
in the 3-2 program for biomedical
engineering excellent
I got an engineering physics degree
there you go something in common
we're here today talking about lasers so
have you had much exposure to lasers yet
that's cool
not yet I am really hoping that we will
I think it's super interesting just the
field in general because I really do
enjoy examining all the calculations and
being able to do a little bit more of
the math side effect okay as opposed to
the experimental side of it and seeing
things okay so I'm much more I like to
see the things happening so then the
question is what's so special about
making a light that's intense enough to
actually possibly blow things out
certainly we can blow atoms up with the
laser hammer and the laser light comes
in and just smacks the electron right
off the atom and so the question really
is is how do you make that back in the
70s and into the 80s I know that's a
long time ago for you we had big energy
lasers and we had short pulse lasers we
couldn't have big energy short pulse
lasers and actually it was my supervisor
and I that figured the way around that
and we got something called chirped
pulse amplification have you heard of
chirped pulse a awful fication by any
chance vaguely well I brought a little
bit of a prop to explain how chirps
pulse
amplification works our short pulses are
made of different colors I've got a
colored slinky here we probably could
have called it stretched pulse
amplification but that's kind of boring
so we used the word chirped the word
chirped comes around because birds chirp
when the birds are singing the notes are
actually changing audio frequency with
time and that's a chirp the point is
that when all the light is squeezed
together like this it's a short pulse
and that's when it's a hammer because
all the light is now concentrated and
you can imagine if this was coming along
and also using a lens to focus it small
than all of that light at the focal spot
concentrate and so that was the laser
hammer so we can't have that in the
laser so the question is what could we
do the fact that it's different colors
and different colors because of
dispersion travel different speeds
inside material so we used a long fiber
one point four kilometers of fiber but
in fiber the red colors really haven't
got that much in common with the glass
atoms and so they spend very little time
you know interacting and they travel
fast the red is going to start traveling
faster than the green faster than the
blue and as you travel down the fiber
next thing you know you have a long
pulse and it's chirped from red at the
beginning to blue at the back and so the
frequencies go whoo okay so this is a
chirped pulse and now it's a long pulse
and so first this is what we did we
chirped it we stretched him then we can
safely amplify it because it's not all
concentrated and after we amplify it
then we use something called a
compressor and we put all of the colors
back together and it was back being
short pulse but a high-energy pulse and
to get that we really had what I like to
call it laser hammer when this laser
pulse goes inside it smacks those
electrons right off the atom so the
laser hammer that you were describing
with other types of lasers and the one
in the tripped is it's still the same
premise well a lot of lasers and when
lasers first came along there were only
single color your cat to are below to be
a singer color probably a red one and so
that's just one color and one color
means that it has to really be there for
the whole time one color is one
wavelength of light and so it's just one
wave that goes on and on and on if you
want a short pulse you actually have to
have all the colors and if you can
imagine at one point in time and I like
to say it's like a conductor of an
orchestra when you're listening to an
orchestra warm up they sound terrible
they're all playing their own notes but
when the conductor conducts them they
all play different notes but together
it's beautiful music so we have
something in a laser called a mo blocker
and it's like the conductor and it says
to go now and all the colors will start
together but some colors are long
wavelength and others are shorter so
next thing you know you have peaks
meeting valleys and they cancel each
other and so the more colors you can
bring in the faster that happens and the
shorter the policy committees the
necklace is something that was designed
for my Nobel Prize it's sold at
Nobel Museum and it is a chirped pulse
so we've been talking a lot about lasers
and applications what have you learnt
about your pulses I learned that it all
stretches which is super cool because
red moves the fastest and so it kind of
tugs around blue it really threw me off
just how fast it's hard to imagine
things happening that fast and I also
learned how many of the things that I
know are lasers and how many of the
things that I've been looking for like
the answers to it is in lasers so I
understand you in grad school where I
don't know why you and what he's
studying I'm studying soft matter
physics which in was the physics of
squishies stuff we make micro swimmers
in the laboratory and we drive them with
a laser and what kind of laser to use we
use a 10 watt laser it's a fiber laser
do you know a lot about lasers or just
about the laser that you use not about
you just a little bit okay so this is
about high intensity lasers no no how do
you make them but what was really
stopping them being made in both cases
nonlinear optics you know we want to do
something that requires a huge photon
density application yes and so that's
how come we came up with chirp false
amplification so that we could stretch
the pulse safely amplify it then
compress it at the end and then we're
ready to do whatever we want at the end
so what do you think the main difference
is between the continuous-wave laser
that you have that runs at 10 watts and
a chirped pulse amplifier I feel like
the continuous laser delivers power to
continuous rate whereas you want all
that power to be delivered in a really
really short time but with your
amplification and so we get the power
with a lot less energy because it's
power is energy per unit time sorry we
aren't depositing much energy in
comparison yes can I just ask cos sure
you are using the thermal process of it
heating up but is have you ever had the
opportunity to use a laser tweezers I
have yeah we use optical tweezers to
trap particles
institution okay and and twirl the
motors are not told the motors I know I
haven't what you're over that okay so I
was always curious how much further like
what higher power can we go now so trip
falsification took a sort of fun we were
at ten to the twelve but when I was
working the ten to the twelfth sort of
sat on a football size field it was a
kilojoule laser with a nanosecond pulse
okay and we brought it down to something
we'd call tabletop terawatt so it was
the same terawatt but now it was one
jewel in one picosecond so it could fit
on a basic optical bench like you would
have in your lab we were able to take
that up to I think the record is right
around somewhere between 10 to the 22
and 10 to the 23 watts per square
centimeter so then and going forward one
of the Holy Grails is can we reach ten
to the twenty-nine watts per square
centimeter so we saw six orders so we've
gone from ten to the twelve to ten to
the 23 so we've done you know eleven
order so you think six isn't so much
harder I have to tell you over time it's
rolling over its we need another Nobel
prize-winning idea but if we get out
there that's where if you focus the
intensity the energy in that volume is
enough to break the vacuum we could
probably use this to drive chemical
reactions at a very very specific spot
like if we wanted I get just a single
cell in the body yes and and and maybe
what do pump probe spectroscopy and
watch the cell or to ionize it I mean I
was thinking more on the lines of if we
want to let's say destroy one cell like
I do myself or something like that so
that neighboring areas are not affected
but just the cell
thanks I don't know if people working on
that because I'm not so much of the
reticle field but I should look into
that and see if that's a possibility so
after hearing about high intensity
lasers can you think about next time you
go back to the lab and you're wondering
how to do something in the love with
lasers can you see how short pulses
might help you
I think short pulses might have been my
experiment in the sense that if I Drive
my swimmers with a continuous wave as
opposed to a pulsed wave
maybe a continuous wave would heat up
the sample too much and a pulsed laser
would deliver
power exactly where I need it so that I
could run my experiment from there maybe
that's true thank you very much thank
you nice to meet you hello Donna good to
see you here with me so we go way back
1991 year I got married I moved across
the country left my husband in New
Jersey Sark with you at Livermore I
remember very much and how hard it was
to convince you to travel across the
country and work at the lab and stay
there and stay there I couldn't convince
you to stay you could not get through
this day though especially there long
enough to make a big impression and get
some good work done and I've been
talking sort of starting with sort of
what is a laser through linear optics
nonlinear optics high intensity laser
physics and saying that you know we're
trying to get to that showing her limit
of ten to the twenty-nine watts per
square centimeter we're at about
somewhere just shy of 10 to the 23 I
think at this point but even if we get
to 100 petawatts and focus that down to
a wavelength we're not at ten to the
twenty-nine yes so you're hoping to
build the biggest laser yes at Rochester
but we're still not going to get to the
stronger limit isn't that right so just
a little bit of back history again after
you you know demonstrated CPA I was
intrigued by how powerful could we make
lasers and then how lasers are wonderful
because you know they allow you to take
energy and compress it in space and time
so having high peak power and something
it's been a motivator for me for a long
time and so we at the University are
making proposals to build 225 petawatt
lasers maybe 30 petawatt lasers we'll
use them to be able to get combined
power of the over 10 to the 24 watts per
square Center still far from the swinger
limit but we have a trick we're going to
use one of these petawatt lasers to make
an electron beam and this electron beam
will be relativistic we actually think
we could make electron beam maybe even
hundreds of GEB up to a TV which would
be another nobel prize that's right you
can do that go for it and then we will
shine that laser onto that electron beam
and the electrons bris frame we meet the
swinger limit okay that's kind of
cheating that's not getting to ten to
the twenty nine if you
do it with 100% efficiency that's all we
need that's why I wanted that Nobel
Prize because again if we're able to do
this you know it's way as I can see
today right I can see us doing it today
by just exploiting it what we already
know and take it to a limit then that
would be a real motivator I think to be
able to even take these texts needs
further cheating is not the right exact
word is taking advantage of relativity
take advantage of all physics not just
optical physics since that's why we want
to do it this way we have to get into
entertainment when is the high intensity
laser gonna get into entertainment so
then there's real money yes yes well we
have started the photon torpedoes that's
why what they actually knew what you
were doing is if you ever seen a start
though Star Trek had like science
fiction no Star Trek had photon
torpedoes and they show bursts of light
about this long it was the same thing
because if he's down a second pulse it
how much energy it carried and you can
see it but I'm what it was scattering
off of but you could see it so it was a
great thing so we can either cheat by
doing laser accelerating and going into
that rest frame yes and that's like you
said we're stuck a little bit we're not
up to that kind of acceleration so that
would be a Nobel prize-winning possibly
or we need going around and giving my
talks now I show how her plateauing I
showed how there was a plateau see PA
raises it up but we're sort of started a
plateau again and we need another Nobel
Prize winning idea and so do you think
it's on the horizon do you see anything
out there that really says oh yeah
that's that's a good way to go because
we're going to have to get out to the
x-rays right we can't we can't stay in
the visual so actually I think you do
there's a potential ways of doing it
with optical or near optical radiation
and you know there's been a lot of work
done in the Defense Department officers
of how do I combine laser beams together
okay and make them act as a one coherent
source so one of the things that we'll
be doing with our two petawatts we're
going to see if we can actually combine
them into a 15 if you can do that you
can begin to imagine doing this with
many lasers many petawatt lasers of the
scale we're talking about so one could
possibly see an X want from that you
know which I you know people have been
able to combine tens of lasers together
for a coherent source so you have to be
able to phase lock them you have to be
able to make them you know there
fazes be exactly connected and related
and be able as they propagate through
all the different optical components
whatever may be just and don't you think
that's the process the entire Appetit
it's because it's not like our beams are
as perfect as we all like to think they
are so it's right so you have to have so
over the Aperture Science you have to
have them phase-locked across the entire
aperture which will be a great challenge
and people done again with small lasers
the laser will be trying to is about 40
centimeter aperture so we'll begin to
start looking at this and actually wave
fun control I mean be able to adaptive
optics other ways which you can control
the uniformity of the phase is something
that's been developed in lots of ways
now here for defense applications for
science applications so we'll do our
best to make use of all these
technologies lasers I think have
progressed so much just like the
semiconductor business because there's
such a market or there's so many
different applications okay so there's a
lot of us working around the world on
these high intensity lasers and so what
do you think the real fun is what do you
see the real excitement being I remember
when the laser was first demonstrated in
1960 what could we do with this we
already got light now we can't live
without lasers my cell phone that is in
my pocket has billions of transistors
how is that made with lasers you know
all integrated circuitry is done with
lasers actually now it's being using
x-rays made from Blaser he didn't matter
that came out of the laser fusion
program so it is amazing the parallels
and optics is used everywhere we're
going to possibly take over from CERN
and let's we'll just do high-energy
physics no lasers we're looking at
gravity waves with lasers we want to do
black holes with lasers we want a
machine with lasers we want to do
medicine with lasers everywhere and now
with the Nobel Prize people are hearing
more about it so they know lasers are
everywhere I couldn't agree with you
more and you winning Nobel Prize has
been an inspiration to lots of people
only three women have won the Nobel
Prize in Physics and only one educated
in the United States and I use that
every place ok and only one Canadian
there you
[Laughter]
today was fun I got to explain the work
I do at all levels it's always fun for
me to talk to elementary school students
because they bring such enthusiasm with
a student who's already started to learn
optics to a graduate student and finally
my own colleague where we can really get
into a huge conversation about what's
the future of this field electronics was
the technology for the 20th century and
it brought us the transistor electrons
don't move nearly as fast as light and
so trust me photonics will take us where
we want to go in this century
[Music]